you got this section in the book that
talks about what you're talking about
right now the leadership Factory right
so here I'm gonna go to the book all the
academic classes in the world will never
teach anyone to be a leader the Academy
recognized that long ago and while we
had to take courses on the subject we
learned by doing the Academy is
structured to provide leadership
opportunities in a wide variety of
places and levels from the very first
day you start as plebs and this is
emphasizing what you just said and
discipline is something that I talk
about all the time and I know what's
great as you know as I was talking to on
the way over here you know I do I do all
these I read these leadership or not
leadership books they're not book it's
about leadership they're about combat
right but combat is about leadership so
all these books all of them every single
one of them whether it's an ancient
Roman military leader or a marine in
Vietnam or an Army soldier in World War
two they all there is one common thing
that's discipline discipline discipline
it's always there back to the book
discipline forms the cornerstone of any
military team and of course punishment
serves as one of the means to maintain
discipline during my junior year I
learned not to be afraid to mete out
punishment at the same time doing so
requires a balance of appropriateness
and understanding so that's why you just
talked about right there and this again
goes to something that I talk about a
lot which is which is the dichotomy of
leadership which is in leadership
there's there's opposing forces that are
pulling you into different directions
and both of them are right they're both
right it's right to be hard on your guys
and maintain strict discipline and it's
right to love your guys and take care of
them you have to balance those two and
that's what you're talking about right
there that's where you were talking
about when you were talking about they
need to understand why they're being
punishment punished
back to the book bad officers try to be
buddies with their Marines there's a
fine line between getting to know your
know getting to know the men under your
command and
hunting with them as friends it is all
too easy to make that mistake
at the same time here's the balance at
the same time if a young second
lieutenant doesn't make an effort to
know his men his aloofness becomes a
drag and will hinder his ability to
command in several ways
first he won't understand the strengths
and weaknesses of his squads more
important he won't have the respect or
the connection needed to motivate and
lead in the worst of circumstances men
will follow other men into the worst
possible circumstances if they respect
and believe in their leadership like all
other aspects of command it is a
delicate balance
so you're just everything you just said
you say it in the book and that's why
we're talking about the leadership
Factory but it's interesting this is
stuff that I'm sure they touched on it
in the classes but that's the stuff that
you learn you learn it from senior
enlisted people you learn it from other
officers you learn it yourself you work
for people and you go man this guy's
aloof this guy's not talking to us so
stuff that we learned ourselves too I'm
gonna finish this section up I concluded
the proper balance here depended on the
officers ability to listen and accept
input while still making it clear that
he was the ultimate decision-maker that
was the key a second lieutenant couldn't
be afraid to engage in frank and
productive dialogue with his key leaders
a platoon becomes the reflection of its
commander he sets the example and this
is from what you just said if his
uniform is jacked up his men won't care
about their own this leads to
disciplinary issues and becomes a very
slippery slope the only way a second
lieutenant can have the moral authority
to set a high standard is to set a high
standard for conditioning and appearance
is to speed the example himself without
conditioning a platoon cannot achieve
its potential in the field
aggressiveness suffers appearance breeds
pride and reinforces discipline and
esprit de corps so those that's the
leadership factory that you're talking
about and clearly those things that you
brought from the football field and from
the
you apply them right directly into your
folks in combat they helped and you know
the Marine Corps has a really unique
circumstance where they have the basic
school or every single officer goes
there and that's huge
this is this huge standard then we go a
step further where when we go to
infantry officer course that course was
13 weeks long one of the very hardest if
not the hardest in the Marine Corps
mentally physically everything you don't
know anything that's coming everything's
a surprise but I felt that my
instructors during our course were
phenomenal and they were getting all the
real-time intelligence from the
battlefield
all the training was realistic but in
terms of how you relate to your Marines
from your junior enlisted to your middle
rank to your senior enlisted how you
relate to the senior enlisted from the
battalion who work directly for the
battalion staff how you manage those
relationships to maximize the
effectiveness of your platoon to make
sure that you can get exactly what they
need they did such a good job of that
then you take it one step further when I
reported 3rd battalion 2nd Marines I'd
be remiss if I didn't give credit to a
guy by the name of Gabe Diana who is a
lieutenant colonel in the Marine Corps
now I believe but he taught me he was a
true student of leadership and military
history he would tell me all the time
his craft is his hobby there's nothing
else he cared about it's what he was he
loved being a Marine loved being an
officer and he taught me a lot about
decentralized leadership how to not
micromanage how to empower your junior
leaders that they start to think like
you and you could achieve tempo on the
battlefield and and you could
immediately see examples of Marines I
call it and I see it all the time in the
business world
I call it JV leadership where I'm a
great leader if my people love me
and and they're the same leaders that
will tell their people all right guys
today we've got to save 30 minutes
longer because headquarters said so look
I disagree with it I think it's
ridiculous but we have to do it so let's
just sit here together now none of their
people are actually gonna work motivated
there's me no discipline there's gonna
be no standard that they're trying to
achieve because of that
leadership they're angry at headquarters
absolutely they're there their bat mad
at the chain of command exactly they did
JV leadership and I'm constantly trying
to talk to people about that a JV
leadership the first thing of it is you
think you have to be loved to be an
effective leader if you are an effective
leader over the long term you will be
loved but there's gonna be intermittent
parts where they can't stand you
they don't understand things all the
time or they're gonna be mad at you in
there because because they're emotional
but over long term they're gonna
understand that what you did was best
the other the second major part that JV
leadership is thinking hey I'm in charge
therefore I come up with all the great
ideas and I'm gonna make every single
decision without your input and I'm
gonna I'm gonna really try hard to make
sure buddy knows I am in charge that's
ridiculous
it is not your job to come up with all
the great ideas some of the best ideas I
receive or from 19 year olds you have 21
year olds who had already been dialogues
had a great sir I got a great idea
well I want to hear all about it's it's
it's our job as leaders to decide which
are the best ideas to invest energy time
and resources in and that's not just I
get all this stuff all the time when I
talk to different groups and companies
well military leadership is different
than corporate leadership why what am I
saying here that does doesn't apply well
it's too extreme it is not you're taking
us too literal with with with our
warrior mentalities here you know that
you do not need to be an insecure the
best leaders are not insecure they're
secure they know that they're there and
ultimately gonna make the final decision
but it empowers your people and you
could achieve tempo when you're
decentralized enough that they feel good
about coming up with ideas sending them
up to you to get back up for it and get
resources behind it but also knowing
that they can make the appropriate
decisions at their level because they
know it your final intent is here's the
outcome I want achieved you get us there
you're the expert at that's why I hired
you I didn't tell my machine gunners how
to work their T&E system and how to cite
in their machine guns right I just told
them what I wanted them to hit they're
better than that at me taking the time
to spend it with my Marines in their
different functions and aspects and talk
to them about how they're there the
expert
and complement them like that it made
them feel great it does wonders for a
leader to go to their level see what
they do every day and and see that
expert work because they don't expect
you to be an expert in all of that they
know that right
your job is different your
responsibilities are different you need
to have greater perspective but when you
go to their level in respect what they
do and show them respect for what they
do and how they do it man it's a
powerful thing that that kid that could
make a group of people so much better
collectively than they ever would have
been individually and when it happens
right when it finally when you finally
get there and can achieve that it is it
is awesome it's the most rewarding
experience you could ever have and it's
hard for people to understand because
most people that well the most rewarding
experience you guys know they have is
killing people no it's so much different
than that so much different there's so
much more to it than that yeah yeah it's
interesting to that by the way what
you're saying right now is basically the
entire book that my buddy laughs
babbling there's a chapter in there
called decentralized command everything
you're saying so but it and that's why
you know you've come up in a completely
different you know in the Marine Corps I
was in the in the in the Navy and yet
you know you and I have both I can tell
right now basically completely aligned
leadership principles isn't it
interesting though that some guys don't
get it they don't get it and you could
explain it to them and you'd say listen
man hey you don't need to make every
decision and in fact when you get out in
the firefight you won't be able to make
every decision you're gonna have to let
your leaders lead and you're gonna let
the afterlife and the and they would
listen to you and you could see it going
right through your head
it's wild you wonder what psych
psychologically is going on in there
makes you want to repel and a lot of
times it's hey they got a bad review
from this officer so this is their way
of saying you know hey you know go fly a
kite you know that this is their way of
rebelling and I noticed that with some
officers and in some of the you know I
had I had a fire lieutenant during my
second deployment and and he had this
problem you know he kept feeling he had
to be best friends at this Marines he
spent
we too much time with him talking about
a lot of personal stuff they'd be out on
patrol and nobody would listen to him I
mean it was almost straight mutiny and
everyone I had to fire and and here was
the thing is I tell him look you're a
really good person and you are most
likely going to be very successful in
whatever you choose to do so please
please remember that it's hard to hear
that now this is a very unique job and
we are in a very dangerous scenario
already in Iraq and we were in a
dangerous area at the time and things
were about to go south and I had to
remove this kid now before things got
worse and it was hard from the
understandthe but you can be a
phenomenal human being a great person
but just not meant to lead especially in
in those circumstances but it's it's
some people and I think obviously if
they have so many years growing up in a
household where it was so different from
what they're being taught that I think
sometimes is the route for them to push
back against this type of leadership no
you know I've been taught differently
for years and years it's kinda like well
how did you just block it all out for
the you know year and a half you've been
in school before you got here with guys
with all this combat experience and not
to mention the hundreds of years of
history yes of combat experience saying
look this is the best way to do it yes
and saying no I'm gonna do it
differently
I mean the military is a business it is
a business it's run like a business and
the leadership there it's about
maximizing the potential of all the
human beings that you have on your team
and how do you do that yes it involves
tactics and what we do is different but
the the personal the small unit down to
the large unit leadership is all the
same Hahnemann it's all the same and you
go around and you talk to different
executives who are having trouble well
you know this you know it's the
Millennials and what they do and what
they do and this do and we were talking
about on the ride here people the
experts always want to blame some kind
of process I think your processing your
information flow is wrong and the way
that you have your workflow set up in
the office space that's causing this
issue in communication no it's not you
saying that because you are afraid to
have the heart conversations with the
leaders who are failing of which by the
way you're one of the leaders yes when
you're failing as a business and you got
these issues yeah its Bree you're gonna
be one of the problems and you might
need help squaring that away and that's
okay that's okay well you know another
thing I noticed in business world is a
lot of people in the business world they
have no leadership training so they've
figured it out they've been lucky and
successful and they've gotten by with
good people and then they get to a
certain point where all the sudden
they're going wait a second I can't
handle this anymore that you know if you
grow from six people that you know
pretty well that you trust and all of a
sudden you've got a staff of a hundred
people if you don't start learning how
to lead you're gonna have significant
problems and it's gonna blow up and that
happens from a hundred people to three
hundred people then from three hundred
people do a thousand people it will
happen every time and you got to train
those leaders throughout the chain of
command that all have the same
understanding of the fundamental
principles of combat leadership which is
leadership you have to throw combat in
there because that was my old job you
know it's funny you bring that up
there's a great example Dan Quinn is the
current head coach of the Atlanta
Falcons he was a defensive coordinator
at Seattle hires a head coach in Atlanta
and threw his he's a very good friend of
Jay Glazer who's obviously very involved
in mixed martial arts and does a lot of
the Fox broadcasts and I've worked with
him in gotten close with him and so Jay
introduced me to Dan dan was looking to
make the team tougher and here's a guy
who has achieved the highest level of
leadership and coaching just like you
talked about he was a great coordinator
now he's a head coach and he had the
humility to seek out experts from all I
mean he went to different sports talk to
their head coaches he went to the
military he went all over with humility
to ask and get advice and glean
experience from other people's time and
leadership to include I couldn't believe
it but Here I am having breakfast at the
man here him in his office or I'm in
there and you know they're little
cafeteria there were just talking
leadership and he's talking about some
his individual guys and he's actually
listening to my opinion wanted to hear
what I went through my opinion on this
guy or that guy is he brought me in to
do some martial arts drills to make the
team tougher but I gained so much
respect that here's a man who's achieved
the highest
he knows he's in charge he's not out to
prove anything
his guys know he's in charge and when
they don't meet the standard there's a
consequence but at the same time he
shows them the same kind of humility as
he seeks out advice to get better every
day
because he wants then hey Julio Jones I
know you think you're the best wide
receiver in football but there's ways
you can get better and you need to be
humble enough to find them and guess
what
Julio goes first in every drill the
dudes that that I've watched him who
works as hard as any human being I've
seen in the football field always
looking to get better Matt Ryan the same
and look at the position the team's at
now but he has continually done that he
turned to Navy SEALs last summer brought
seals and to work with his team to work
with him on leadership on accountability
and all this combat but leadership's
leadership and bring it into that locker
room and create this cohesive unit that
has had a tremendous turnaround from the
2015 season to now 2016 yeah yeah now a
championship again for you reciting my
book which have to do is we have we a
chapter there it's called check your ego
and you know my point is the number one
the number one characteristic that a
leader has to have is humility and if
you don't have that all those things
that you just talked about you won't do
any of them you won't ever get better
you won't listen anybody else you won't
take any advice you can't that's it's a
horrible thing